did all of you go to film school and if
you did do you regret it are you happy
that you went and if you didn't go what
are your thoughts yeah I did go to film
school I went to sort of like a more of
a trade school at a documentary program
Photography it was a bachelor so it was
pretty broad Communication Arts
we did make narrative and fiction and
commercial projects while I was there
you know if I were to do my career in
film over again you know I don't think
film schools is necessary you could
basically start as a production
assistant and and really work your way
up and learn the game which is probably
more valuable to you you know it does
help to have a college degree out there
in the world I work for my you know job
I work in the commercial side of the
business I make commercials produce
commercials but pretty much zero people
have ever asked me what school I
graduated from it's all about the reel
and the portfolio and my network yeah I
did go to college and I got into the
film department and after two years of
it I was I was actually already working
in the industry doing some art direction
and makeup and different things and so I
kept taking time off of school and I
would go and work on something and I was
doing some editing and so finally after
two years and being faced with classes
on like how many gigawatts it takes to
run a satellite dish and all the stuff
that is like I don't need to know I
don't want to know
I dropped out after two years and then
just kept working and I've never stopped
working since and then my real training
was I did special effects for ten years
so my real training was watching Steven
Spielberg work watching held Ramos work
watching commercial director Jo Pitka
work I mean that's where I learned kind
of what you're saying that's that's the
real way to learn it you could certainly
learn the ins and outs and the nuts and
bolts and all and writing classes are
good but
I heard some awful statistic and I think
it was about USC that arguably one of
the greatest film programs in the world
that only something like 1% or 2% of the
people that graduate actually end up
working in the industry some and and I
might have that wrong so don't quote me
on it but it was something incredibly
shockingly low no I never went to film
school my father was a single parent and
decided when I was three years old he
was gonna move to California become a
film director so he jumped in a car and
drove across the from Florida to
California and he's been doing it ever
since so I grew up going to school going
to set going to school going to say at a
certain point I wanted to get away from
the mill from the film industry so I
went join the military to try to get
away from this and I ended up becoming a
photographer back in the business
and I did that for three years for the
US Navy and went work for the government
for six years and got laid off when
Obama did his government contract
cutbacks and then I went in 2009 became
a PA I was a PA for about 10 or 15 films
and they sound called me up to be a line
producer and everything for that point
though now I've done movies
congratulations it's very cool story um
similarly my father was a director as
well so I kind of grew up on set my
whole life and I hated it and then I
ended up going to film school
um so Roger I think the best take the
money from film school and go make a
movie and that was and my dad told me
that he said dude don't go don't go but
I just wanted to get away from home I
was like I am going and and I went and I
definitely made some relationships there
but you're right Roger Corman was right
take the money go make a film because
what I learned was there was no there
was it wasn't like I came out of films
cause like oh wow I have this path to
success
it was just like as if I hadn't gone
I will say and I had to do the same
thing I do you know steal some money and
make a movie you know the one thing that
film school doesn't teach you what
happens if your actor doesn't show up
the next day what happened if the crew
member gets hurt DP is sick all that
stuff is nobody teaches you that and all
the stuff you're learning in school is
your basic camera stuff lighting it's
nothing to do with the actual people
which is where you take the money go
make the movie you'll learn all of them
yeah and I think the one the one place
that I will give film school credit is
allowed me to to incubate creative
thoughts and ideas with being exposed to
new movies and for me as a filmmaker I'm
I'm I love film I base a lot of what I
do off the movies I love and I'm
obsessed and addicted to watching movies
so it did opening up some of that but I
would have loved to have taken that film
put it towards a movie and just gone and
made all the mistakes that ended up
making anyway eight years later I did I
will say that hmm a lot of the big
department heads from on my film or
people I graduated college with so I did
get to have some people around me that
were very talented and that I got to you
know be a succubus and use their talent
for my own I know they're very talented
people and talented people help us make
better films so yeah but do the Roger
Corman plan take the money and make a
film Brian anything my dad was an
optical engineer so I unfortunately and
I grew up in the hills of Tennessee a
hillbilly or as we like to call
ourselves because we were sophisticated
we were Mountain Williams so they didn't
know what what the heck to do with me
wanting to make movies this was like my
whole family had no idea but they kind
of insisted that I was gonna go to
college it was like you you were almost
ran off and join the circus because I
got to I got to intern on a horror film
with Anthony Perkins and
I almost didn't come back the wardrobe
department kind of sucked me in and I
but I almost didn't come back but they
they they got me back and then they said
well you have to go to school and like
well the only thing I care about making
movies so I guess that's what I'll do
and they're paying for it so I did it
my grandfather paid for it it was USC it
was USC cinema school and because I
guess they had a redneck quotient they
needed to fill out and but it certainly
wasn't the movies I'd made it to that
point that got me I agree though it's I
mean it's a different error back then
this is really pre-internet definitely
like going to films go back then maybe
there was a reason for it because you
could get exposed to a lot of movies
that were very difficult to see at that
time period and you could learn from a
lot of people work in the industry to
learn some craft but that's you don't
need to now I mean you haven't needed to
for like ten years I mean now with with
the internet you can see every movie
there is out there you can get feedback
by posting your shorts on YouTube and
you can get feedback from people in the
business I'll do it I mean you don't
really need to do it anymore
one plus side of it is I guess
I I did meet like you said I met some
some great people and when we finished
we ran off and did like a 50 minute
thesis short on our own and that was
probably that was a lot of fun and
learned a lot from that and into the
process of all that I I met my wife who
I make horror films with so so that
weird chain of events if I hadn't gone
my life would have been very different
in a bad way but yeah I I don't think
it's worth going to film school taking
them on if you have money to and you
don't wanna get yourself in debt which
is a bad idea anyway then yes invest it
in a future but please please please
please please do 2030 shorts before you
even think about doing a feature so you
can make a bunch of mistakes and learn
from them so then you can make a bunch
of mistakes when you make your feature
but at least you're making new mistakes
I mean people who never really made a
movie and they say oh I'm gonna do a
feature as this crazy I was like saying
you're gonna write a novel and you've
never in a paragraph I mean it's insane